thank you
agriculture is the main source of
livelihood for 95 percent of the rural
households in Lao PDR
almost 80 percent of this cropped area
is dedicated to growing rice
rice is life for the people of Laos who
have been planting and nurturing their
rice fields for hundreds of years
but the land doesn't always give back
what this farmers put in and with a
country whose birth rate is the highest
in the region at 2.5 percent increasing
rice production to feed their country is
a high priority
in the southern province of Savannah cat
Farmers fields are continually at the
mercy of drought and flooding
unknown to some there is a field here
which has been privy to a specially bred
Lao modern variety or lmv rice plant
s
Village is just one of the many
communities which have been part of the
Lao Erie research and training project a
partnership between the Lao PDR Ministry
of Agriculture and Forestry and the
international rice Research Institute or
Erie this collaborative project was
established in 1990 to assist the
government of Lao PDR to achieve their
National goal of rice self-sufficiency
on a sustainable basis and for more than
a decade of this 15-year partnership
with Erie the Lao people have been
celebrating rice self-sufficiency
and
um
for Laos rice makes up 70 of their daily
calorie requirements
when loud people speak of achieving food
self-sufficiency they mean having enough
rice to eat
a new technology for the right
production is based on the new varieties
new acronym aspect and also increasing
the year
the feedback from the farm are very
important because we we keep the sea to
the family after that we we get the
information from them from 1997 the the
first variety and the farmer grow this
variety and get the high yielding
injections
foreign
over the course of the project 18 new
varieties were released they have been
so successful that three-quarters of the
households using Lao modern varieties
were self-sufficient or had a surplus in
rice while 64 percent of the farmers
planting traditional varieties were rice
deficient
these are high yielding moderate
duration rice varieties which have Eerie
parentage these rice varieties would not
be there today if it were not for the
training and the assistance of the
lawyeri project major achievement is
here in this Jin Bank we keep 13
193 uh
varieties we have to preserve this for
the sustainable used by the researcher
and Farmers to train people to identify
and characterize those accessions and to
use them in a breeding program
below Eerie project has also supported
the establishment of a training center
out at the agricultural Research Center
at a village called Nepal I think the
training is very useful I have learned
English writing report how to collect
rice for research in the cold room the
main thing before going further to
disseminate our technology to the farmer
first we train our participants we train
our staff is
foreign
National right self-sufficiency since
1999. the rice sufficiency of the poor
is estimated to be only 6.8 months in a
year
foreign
environment of Laos Farmers rice fields
slope across the faces of the
Mountainside creating more challenges
for researchers and the farming
communities
thank you